Hey, Michelle.
Good morning.
Emward morning.
Mosam Gaza.
Regarding, bro.
Oh.
How's the weather like over there?
Pretty hot.
It's raining out here, thunderstorm.
Ohh, nice.
It was pretty hot in the day in the day, but right now it was the AM.
Yeah, it was raining yesterday, but not today.
Hey, Mike, good morning.
Hello, hello.
Hey, how are you?
All right.
Apologies, I'm not...
Not at the desk.
Wow.
Sure.
Okay.
Finishing up an orthodontist appointment with my son.
How's it going?
Very good. How about you?
Gregg.
Pre.
A spot where I can try and follow along from the screen on my little phone. Ohh.
Who else are we expecting to join?
Ah.
Keith will be joining in a few minutes and a new guy, Kris.
Ankur.
Yep.
Anyone else from your end who will be joining us today?
I don't know if Aaron's gonna make it or not.
Okay.
Kour.
Hey, Kris.
Hello, Evan.
Hi.
I like.
Hi, how are you?
I'm doing good. What about you?
Oh, alright.
Busy as usual.
So I'm just waiting on Keith, his laptop isn't working.
Hmm.
I bet he knows some people that could fix that.
Yeah.
Yep, he's trying the land now.
Ah, I, I just share my screen and we can start with the NOC first, then.
Okay, Mike, I hope you can see my screen now.
I can't, yep.
Perfect. So Mike, as you know, that drill will be discussing the SLA summary patch and backup compliance Engineers stats and HT as well inventory true about recaps from the last meeting we had. If you talk about the NOC performance in April, overall we got 88 alerts on our end, 19 P1s, 29 P2s and 15 P3s and 25.
For P1, P2, and P3, the response and resolution SLA was 100%. So the performance was excellent for P1, P2, and P3. But P4, there were two tickets which got missed in terms of response SLA by a delay of 2 minutes and four tickets in terms of resolution. These four were quarterly test restores actually.
And these were these were resolved on the 8th day by the by after the confirmation from Dharam actually, but these were quarterly test restore, so did not impact the the actual the tickets we got.
Regole.
Any, any, any questions, Mike?
Ohh...
Nope.
Great, perfect. If you talk about the patch compliance for April, this is the current patch compliance, which we have 30.40. Currently, it is pretty low because the new patches were released yesterday. That's why most of the devices have pending patches right now. And we have the patching window for every Saturday.
and all these devices will be taken care of during this weekend.
Okay.
If you talk about the backup performance in April, we got 13 alerts. Right now, there is only one ticket which is open. So 12 tickets have been closed, but one is open, which is for electrical production services. It is waiting on from Teal, actually. We are just waiting for an update on this one. The backup sheet and the data has been attached for your reference. Please let me know.
in case you have any queries. And if you can get someone to check this ticket, I would appreciate that.
Yeah, what was the, um, what's the nature of that ticket?
It's a backup ticket, I guess P3.
Just.
Or is it just a fail in a failed state?
Right, right. Team just need a few information regarding this and we are just waiting for that.
Phelps.
Cool. Moving on, Helpdesk, Mohit, over to you.
Thank you very much, Barry.
So for the last month, Mike, we have received 15 overall tickets, out of which we have escalated 7 tickets and 8 tickets were closed by our end. Most of the tickets were regarding application issues and remote access issues. But anything from your side that you would like to add for the Helpdesk site?
No.
We have also attached the file along with this slide in the bottom of the slide. So if you want, you can go through that and if there is any query, please let us know.
Okay.
Thank you very much. Over to you, Vishal.
You just called him Barry and he got offended, Mohit, so...
Thanks, Mohit.
Yeah.
I know I was just about to text him that I'm so sorry I've been on so much calls with Barry and now Vishal, I apologize.
The.
Yeah.
Cool, he accepts GPS points as an FYI, but yeah, let's go ahead.
Till till yep.
Still not unhappy, but GPS would be fine.
I will, I will.
Thank you, Vishal. Thank you very much.
All right. So, hey Mike, thanks for your patience. Thanks for waiting. Before I start with the dedicated piece, I just want to inform you that I have Kris on the call with me as well, who is closely working with me on Ontario dedicated Engineers, right? So, Vishal and Barry, they work with me on the NOC front.
Hey.
And then Chris has recently joined with me to manage the Teal Engineers. So you will see him very often on the calls with me. And of course, he will closely work with the engineers. This guy is super technical, has good operation skills as well. So he will be working very closely with the engineers in case they need any assistance, flow support.
or anything, he's going to be there to assist them. And of course, will be supporting me as well. So he'll be joining these calls with us. And I will also add him to the group where me, Aaron, and you are, where we discuss all the leaves and just the basic engineer stuff, just in case if he has any updates for us, if we need anything from him, we can, you know.
use that group for that purpose.
Okay, so will Kris be a, is Kris kind of an internal escalation point for the Engineers?
Right.
Yes, you can consider that as an escalation point as well for sure.
I think, OK.
OK, that's great.
Yep, and he can work as a backup for me as well. So yeah, on both the fronts. Cool. All right, thanks for joining, Kris. We will be jumping on to the dedicated Engineers. I've removed Sophie's numbers from here from the list, Mike. So though she contributed.
well last month, so you will see some, I mean, Allison's numbers won't be to that mark because yes, Sophie was present and she did contribute last month, but from next month onwards, you'll be seeing good numbers for Allison as well since she'll be the only one managing the L1 support. Sophie's last working day, I think, would be this Friday.
And I'll be sharing more information over an email so that we're on the same page. And yeah, that's unfortunate, but I think that's how it is. Aaron did try to connect with Don and see if things could work, could be worked out, but it didn't unfortunately, but it is what it is, I guess. So yeah, looking forward to, you know, growing.
more with you guys. So we will talk about that later, but we jump on to Vipul Saini first. See good improvement with the kill rate. He worked on 55 tickets and close 55, so 100% kill rate there. Overall hours, which used to be a concern initially in the initial phase when I think Vipul was the only engineer in the team, or maybe Geraldo joined, his utilization was low, but.
As you can see, his average is 28.04 per week. He received 5 CSATs, all five of them during this period were 100%. So we're setting 100% achievement from him when the target is 98%. Week one, he closed 10 tickets, week two, managed 15, closed 15, week 3, 12, week 4, 10, and week five, he closed.
Eight tickets, if you can give a one click, Vishal.
So yeah, the utilization as you can see in the first week was 20 hours, 20.31 to be accurate, week 2, 28.63, week 3, 33.05, that was the highest. Week 4, 30.69 and week 5, 27.50 because it was only four days working for him for that week. A few highlights, 100% kill rate.
All 5 weeks, all the tickets he managed was able to close it. Best week was week two with good utilization and good amount of tickets that he managed and closed. With one BTO CSAT, 5 surveys received, all five of them were 100%, rather than all five of them were green. Solid utilization, 140 hours across 22 days that he worked.
The last month in in month in the month of April, but anything you have for Bibble Mike.
No, just positive feedback for Vippal. Vippal does works well with the team, and...
Those valuable asset to us.
Good to hear that. He would love to hear that. Thank you for that. I'll share it with him. And yes, I see he's always, always ready to help. I mean, he's constantly in touch with Sophie and Allison, right? In case they need any assistance, they reach out to him directly. That's the kind of team bonding these guys have. So I'm happy he's taking care of the ones below him.
So yeah, and plus he works in collaboration with Harish a lot to see how they both can contribute to deal. So happy to see that collaboration. But thank you for the feedback. We'll jump on to Alison. I guess that's it's her next. Yep.
Okay, so 131, I think it's the third consecutive month that she's achieved 100% kill rate with 131 tickets assigned and 131 closed. Overall hours, 123.52, average hours, 24.70. So like I said, this also, of course, the number of tickets that she worked on was along with Sophie. Sophie had her good amount of share of tickets that she worked on.
And since she is no longer in the account, next month onwards, I think Allison's numbers will peak up. So yeah, in case she needs any assistance with any sorts of tickets, we'll of course make sure that we let you know. But so far, things look good. And yeah, next week onwards, let's see how things work.
A slide back, please. Yep.
Cool. So 14 surveys for her. All of them were positive. So good feedback for her. Weekly ticket closures. She closed 11 tickets in the first week, 37 tickets in the second week, 31 in the third, 33 in the 4th, and 19 on week 5. Now if we check the utilization for her, week one, her utilization was 13.64 hours. Week 2
peaked up to 31 hours. That was pretty impressive. Week 3, 26 hours. Week 4, again, 32.95. Week 5, with one PTO, four days working, she was sitting at 19.93, worked on 19 tickets, closed 19. Again, a few highlights for her. Perfect 100% kill rate. So third consecutive month, she achieved 100% kill rate, which is pretty impressive.
14 CSATs, Hyacinth team, and she performed there when it comes to CSATs, 0 backlog despite of three PTO days, and best week was week 2 with 37 tickets closed and 31 hours of utilization. Any feedback that you received from Erin for Allison? I think last time she told me that she needs Allison to pick up tickets proactively, which she did this time.
But I want to hear from you if there's anything else you've heard from Aaron for Allison.
Yeah.
Um...
Really just that, just the, you know, the proactive engagement piece. I know in my interactions with Allison, I've always, I'm always pleased and you know, I see Allison's interaction with clients and that's that always seems to go well.
Yeah.
just another valuable contributor.
Nice, nice. Good to hear that. Thank you. All right, that works. And recently, just an FYI, she appeared for a level up interview. She's currently her title internally in ITBD system administrator. She recently appeared for an interview and assessment for a senior system administrator. So that thing did go in the right direction.
I'll just give you the news once I get the results and yeah, maybe you can discuss it or maybe give some kudos to her during your internal connects. But I'll keep you updated.
Yeah, that's great. And Harsh, Harsh making moves too. So Harsh, Harsh shared with me a recent certification that he completed and that's great.
Yeah, yep. Awesome. Perfect. Moving on to, I think next is like Geraldo. It's working slow on my end for some reason. So tickets assigned 608, tickets closed 581. Good amount of tickets managed by him. 95% kill rate, 95.6% kill rate. Overall, I was a...
167 average hours per week, 3.40. Currently has open tickets of 21, and there was one PTO during this period. In week one, he closed 144 tickets. Week 2 is a little low in numbers, 25. Week 3 is 221 tickets, again, picked up. Week 4, 105. Week 5, 86 tickets.
Overall, if I do the segregation, 590 of the tickets that he worked on were backup tickets. 15 of them were patching and three of them were knocked tickets. If I go to the utilization on a weekly basis for him, Vishal.
All right, in the first week, 24 hours utilization, week 3, 31, week 2, rather, 31.25. Week 3 was a major contribution, highlighted red for you, just to showcase number of tickets he worked on with 228. In week 3, close to 21 out of them, 39 hours of utilization across five days in the week. That was impressive.
Week 4, 39.75 utilization again, and week 5, 32.25. Highest ticket volume managed by him in the last three months, 608 tickets were assigned. Week one, perfect, and week 3 stood out with the number of tickets that he managed. Week 5 gap, 14 open tickets from week 5 right now, which he's currently working on, currently assigned to him.
No dependency there. He's just working on those tickets right now. If in case he needs any help, he let us know. I'll let you guys know. And patching cycle, active 15 tickets. April included an active patching cycle, adding 15 patching tickets to the usual backup workload. So yeah, overall I think Geraldo is doing pretty good as well. I have regular connects with him. And yeah.
But anything for Geraldo as such.
Yeah.
Um...
No, I think the volume is just due to the nature of the work that, that you know, the tickets that he is working on with backups, and we'll sometimes see multiple errors, you know, in one job, you know, for a given client, so the volume, the volume makes sense.
Mm.
Overall, please with Geraldo.
Mhm.
Nice. Good to hear that. Good to hear that. Perfect. We'll share the kudos with him. Moving on to Harsh. Harsh is doing really good. Of course, the number of tickets for him is pretty less, of course, because he works on the escalated ticket. If you have any feedback on that piece, I'll capture that in a bit. But yeah, he worked on 16 tickets, worked on 16, closed 11 out of them, 68.8% of kill rate.
Yes.
Overall hours one 21.50, average hours per week 24.30. He received just one ticket each in week one and week two. Those tickets were not closed to zero. As you can see there, closures for week one and week two, week three. He closed three. He closed four in week four and four in week 5 as well. If I check the utilization per week for him.
It is not loading yet. Thank you. Week 1, 20.83 hours. Week 2, 13.59 hours. Week 3, 32.37. Well, week 2 was lower comparatively because he was on leave for three days. So 2 days worked only and week one as well. He was able to work for three days only because of two PTOs.
So yeah, probably that's why the number of tickets that were assigned to him were low. Week 3, 5 tickets, sorry, five days worked, 32.37 hours, and he was able to close three out of five tickets that were assigned to him in week three. Close all four of them, all four of the tickets that were assigned in week four with 30.73 utilization, and week five as well, 23.98.
assigned 5 tickets, closed four out of them. But yeah, he manages much more critical tickets, but would like to hear from you if there's anything you think he's doing wrong or something should be added to his day-to-day work, or how do you think things are for him?
I've noticed, you know, I've noticed improvement in his engagement and ownership of issues, and I expect that, you know, I expect that to increase. We're going to start escalating more and sending more.
Okay.
To harsh.
Yeah.
Perfect.
So, yeah, we've had some, we've had some staffing, we've had some more staffing changes, you know, on the on the teal side. One of our senior Engineers left last week, so that creates that creates a little bit of a gap, so I expect to engage harsh.
Mm.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
More in the coming weeks, you should see his numbers increase.
Sure.
Kour.
Absolutely, absolutely. I'm sure he'll be able to contribute well here and he'd be happy with it as well. Okay, perfect. Thanks for that. I'll share the information with him so that he's just aware of how the situation is. Perfect. I think that's about it. If you can switch to the next slide. Over to you, Michelle.
Thanks, Keith. So currently we are managing 183 servers and host along with 10 workstations. So total count would be 193 devices. Any changes, Mike, in the inventory that we have right now?
Uhh...
I have to put through the spreadsheets to.
To really, really reconcile.
Sorry for that, Mike. I think you cannot see my screen right now.
Hello.
Gagan.
No, I can't.
No, he can't. Yeah, my monitor is off.
No, it just went away.
Yeah, there's a power cut tip. Yep. Yeah.
She has a power power outage or something.
Looks like everybody's sitting in the dark.
Oh yeah, it's a superstorm outside.
Yes, it was same here, like...
We got from Chandigarh now.
Yeah.
Gregg.
Ah.
Yep, Healey, we are back.
There you go.
Haha.
Okay, yeah, so we were at the inventory, right? Any changes that we should expect, Mike, soon? Any client that you guys are onboarding?
Um, we've got, we've got a few clients that are in the...
Onboarding state.
Um...
Eight.
Yeah, we've got, you know, we've got some standard, just kind of, we have some some some leaving, some some coming, some going.
Perfect.
Okay, cool, cool.
Okay, there were no to-dos from the last meeting we had. Anything you want me to add here for either for the NOC team or anyone from the delegate as well?
Mm.
Nope.
I would, I would like to talk, talk to you, Keith, about.
Resumes for possible security analyst.
some analyst work that we have. And it's really, you know, with the focus, I need somebody that can hit the ground running, that's familiar with Sophos, the Defender Suite, tools like Qualys,
Um...
Black Point.
I can give you more, I can give you more buzzwords and tools that tools that we use, but I'm curious to see if you've got.
an expert on staff or what level of skill you might have.
You're on mute.
Keith, you are on mute.
My bad, my bad. Absolutely. And in case you have like a brief JD, a job description of what that person would be expected to do, it'll be easier for me to do that search for you so that I can have that one. I mean, I can, I'll be able to get that one suitable candidate.
Ohh.
Sure.
candidate for you. If not internally, they'll quickly raise a request with the TA and I'll have to give them the JD and get somebody hired from the external by the external team here. So if you can share that with me, sorry, I just got diverted. I was sharing that information.
Yeah.
As we speak, also, I think we need to, if I, if you have a minute, maybe once the call is done, you have any other slides with you, Vishal, and then I think if not, then you can.
No, just the informational one.
Okay, then you can stop the share and if you guys, none of you have any questions or queries, you guys can drop. I can have a minute with Mike if that's okay.
Sure, yep, all good from my end. Thanks, Mike.
Sarbjeet.
Thanks, Johal.
Thank you, everyone. Thank you, Mike.
Appreciate it.
Thank you, Evan.
Thank you, Mike.
Right. So, hey Mike, so I have noted you said the person should have knowledge on Sophos, the vendor 3, callers, back point. Okay, we have a database here that I can check and figure if I have anybody readily available, but at the same time, I do ask you before in case I need to.
Mhm.
get a person searched from market from outside. Do we have a budget in mind, a range, so that I can, you know, look at, look for the candidate accordingly?
The.
You know, something that I, something that I just, just a thought that came up on this call, you know, because I'm short on cybersecurity resources and I've got a backlog of analyst work. So I've been searching for another, I've been searching for a candidate. We have a
Yeah.
open, you know, an open job description on our website. And I don't have all of the details, long way of saying I don't have all the details readily available for you because it was just something that just popped into my mind while I was talking to you. Typically, you know, we, for our cybersecurity team, we typically
Right.
Okay.
Mhm.
Needs.
clearable folks, you know, that our citizenship is a requirement or a clearance may be a requirement with some of our clients. So it's something that it's a position that we really want to hire, you know, internally for. But
Looking at the backlog of work that I have, I'm open to options, I guess. I can get you more detail.
Yeah.
Mmh.
Surely. Absolutely, absolutely. I mean, if I, even if I get a ballpark figure, because when I request a request to, when I request the TA team to find an external resource for me who suits the JD that I've shared with them, they do ask me for a window at least, so that when they go out looking for an engineer for a candidate, they do check with that person's expectation.
expectations as well. So yeah, just based on that, we want to make sure that whosoever we select should match the requirements and should match the budget as well, your budget, our budget. And then of course, both that we can go with the interview rounds and all that. So in case you have a ballpark figure in mind, even if it's a wide range, that will help as well so that we have at least an idea.
And then, yes, we can, we can of course work on on the on the figure later on, but at least if you have a range, a window, that'll that'll help.
Thakur.
Right.
I'm also, I'm also wondering.
Mm.
Harsh's Microsoft experience. I'll have to talk to him about how much he knows about the Defender Suite.
Okay.
He may be able to help me with some of the, he may be able to help me with some of the Defender deployments that I...
Right.
Mhm.
that I need to tackle.
Mm.
Absolutely. And looking at his experience, even if he doesn't have expertise or his skill set doesn't allow that, I'm pretty sure he will get things ready for you. One certification or one training, and I think he's going to be on track for you and can be of some use because of the technical knowledge and
Yeah, I'm gonna talk to him about that.
I'm sorry.
I said, yeah, I'm going to talk. I'm going to talk to him about that.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely, absolutely. And if there's any certification required, any training required, and if I have the resources here, I can get them trained. So whatever suits you guys, just let me know. Plus, I'm going to do a quick search internally first for the security analyst that he talked about. If there's anybody who matches the skill set, I'll quickly get that person introduced to you, a quick assessment maybe with you.
If I'm not able to find anybody internally, I'll definitely connect with the TA team to find somebody from external. But again, for that, I would require a ballpark figure, which I can maybe if you don't have anything handy right now, you can share that with me along later along with the JD if possible, Mike.
Okay, yes, let me let the let me let me let the talk.
Right.
Blake, bake for a little while, and then I'll get back, I'll get back to you on it.
Sure, but I'm still searching internally for this role, right? I do that homework on my side.
Yeah, if you do have, if you look for those skills, just for those kind of, those tools and skills, if you have someone available, you know, on the bench or something,
Absolutely.
Sure.
Mhm.
Interested?
Okay, right, right. That works. Anything else? Any, I mean, post Sophie's exit, of course, my heart broke there because I had a pool of five Engineers for a deal, but it's down to four now. But anything you feel there might be an expansion again in future or?
What do you think how things are for Teal and ITBD?
Yeah, you know, I've...
Yep, I'm kind of relying on Aaron for a lot of the management day-to-day of the tier one, tier 2 folks.
Yeah.
I am cautiously optimistic, but you know, I...
I'm concerned about call volumes and how we're gonna be able to service, you know, the call queue and...
Yeah.
All that good stuff, so we'll see, we'll see how it goes.
Sure, sure, because I was wondering myself, like Allison, if you saw the numbers, she handled 131 tickets last month. And if let's say Sophie handled about 100, so that's going to be on an average 200 plus tickets or 230 tickets for Allison in a month.
let's say an emergency leave from her is going to burden, I mean, the internal engineers for deal, I guess, with those numbers. So, I mean, I think having two engineers at least so that they can work as backup was, I mean, if we, if you ever think of hiring a entry level L1.
is in future, if Sophie wasn't working out, maybe we can look for somebody else at lower price or whatever. But I think having two Engineers on the level one position sounds like a good idea because one of them call out sick, it would become a headache for Aaron. And that's just a suggestion. Rest, everything is your call.
Yeah.
Right, but yeah, just giving a suggestion that.
Maybe if you can, maybe it's worth considering.
Yeah.
Right.
A little bit of a lull in activity, and you know, and so we had part of the team focused on routine housekeeping, maintenance, you know, health checks, true-ups, and inventory, you know, inventory true-ups and things like that, so there was, I think there was a little bit of a little bit of a dip in in.
Mhm.
Mm.
Mmh.
Volume, but I don't know that that's going to be sustained.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
We'll see.
Right, yeah, maybe like Sophie's last working day would be this Friday and then a month from now, when we connect next, I guess, we will get more idea on how the volume is and how it's being handled for sure. Makes sense.
Yeah, we will.
Alrighty, alright. Always a pleasure talking to you, Mike. It's been a while. Thank you for joining the call, and yeah, we'll stay in touch.
Alright, thanks for your time. Appreciate it.
Kip.
Yeah, it has been a while. Yeah. All right.
Yeah.
All right. Thank you, Mike.
Thanks, Keith. See you.
Right, bye.